dronde exclusion sur d'autres options
pissia j'ai goûté on a vu mes créations
qui sont vraiment génial des inventions
hors norme et je me suis dit que c'était
peut-être vient de montrer des créations
d'amateurs de temps en temps elle va
être un petit peu en avant à côté de mon
talent pour la
c'est les vaisseaux que j'ai téléchargé
sur le bête bien évidemment attention
première invention c'est juste un hockey
à wiltord avance you donc là le gars
juste fait un gaou style de break
dancers et tu peux marcher avec et
breakdance et par terre par exemple
voilà bonsu les nuls mais attendez
regardez celui ci c'est pas beau deux
personnes qui vont se faire un câlin
comme ça ça vous fait pas arriver quand
même et ce rouge ou pas guy siège pour
voir ça ça de fer qui avant sexuelle
attendait jusque là au regard des
bêtises mais aussi des trucs de malade
mental par exemple ça je me suis trompé
ça c'est juste un canard qui peut
avancer comme un canard mais c'est quand
même c'est à dire que c'est quand même
super compliqué à faire le mec a du
talent mais pourquoi il n'a pas utilisé
ce talent pour faire autre chose comme
de canard qui se fait d'un marché
mordelles baa le kanak qui brûlent
maintenant ça devienne nuggets
c'est quoi ça wat au haut à salage des
bons mais ça n'a aucun sens
réa le mec ce qu'il a fait un sale type
elle du nord et on peut vraiment marcher
avec
regardez au dernièrement une sorte de
mille pattes des gueules vous avez vu ça
marche bien en plus ça voilà
bon j'avoue c'est un vent chaud a pu
péter du jour adresse vendirent cédé que
attendait au attendant puisque je dirais
le truc bien alors ce amex assez
improbable le gars fait un avion capable
de vraiment bien s'écraser mon gars
regarde le gaffeur et avions qui marche
super bien en plus de ça qui va super
vite mais quand même je suis juste
impressionné par le talent de cet homme
quoi mais que c'est juste scandaleux par
contre pour tenter c'est un peu
compliqué j'avoue que ça je préfère les
hélicoptères au moins on peut tourner
sans avoir à aller super vite voilà
c'était l'instant opinion sur tout ce
qui est rien l'actualité maintenant
alors ça c'est le genre de robot mais
qui sait tout faire
mais vraiment et garder il peut avancer
il peut reculer par exemple il peut
tourner sur lui même
hier ça c'est une belle avancée regardez
on peut aussi bouger les bras à aller
vers l'intérieur et l'extérieur c'est
quand même pratique et en appuyant sur h
les bras s'agrandissent fc le lance
flammes
et attention on peut avoir des canons à
eau pour éteindre l'oci ont propre à
bombay où l'intervention d'éric je
faisais des démonstrations de moi un
jury quan on s'est fait des trucs comme
ça et ça je peux vous dire que c'est
beaucoup plus dur à faire
alors ça c'est génial hausse de la
veille qui s'amuse à faire des vrais bd
vraie représentation de choses là c'est
juste quelqu'un qui pousse qu'elle
craque et suranné ça c'est la perfusion
c'est un peu glauque comme c'est un peu
glauque
regardez regardez comme c'est beau mais
ça marche pas bien par contre dans le
mec qui pousse teulier plus malade que
le mec qui est dans le rien fait il sera
pas sans un arrêt dié mes amis je me
suis trompé tout c'est en fait la
meilleure invention du monde regardez
[Musique]
j'ai trop faim on doit il a fait un truc
qui lance 15 missiles mais le lanceur
prend feu et explosé contrairement à
semer ce qui lui arrive à faire atterrir
le lanceur d'une fusée
mais aussi des choses très utile comme
par exemple cette véritable manne et qui
peut se refermer
attendez je dois du coup peut avancer et
ça se casse le mec est quand même fort
pour faire ça alors pourquoi il n'a pas
fait un avis au bordel ça se trouve dans
la vraie vie appareils par exemple ça
s'ouvre le gars qui a inventé la passe à
l'orge
il avait les capacités pour inventer un
ascenseur qui a même dans l'espace mais
non il a préféré faire les pinces à
linge explications longues échéant
dislike et souple est faible kung fu
gagne 3,2 axa fait du kung fu si on fait
ça vite regardez on dirait presque
qu'ils se battent à temps c'est une
sorte de coup au flop
écoutez j'éprouve du plaisir tout de
même à casser ce robot ou presque pas du
coup pourquoi ils s'appellent concours
aux bottes hockey et qu'on foute
mesdames et messieurs voici la pub
machine qui finalement a des petits
problèmes d'intestins et qui doit vomir
je suis trompé dans le lancement par
deux en fait vous faire ça voilà il a
vomi
mesdames et messieurs voici la créature
qui courent la plus vite de toubib
siègerait adobe va faire un test tout de
suite juste un petit chien et il peut
grâce aux arrhes ok aux mondiaux on voit
là mais regardez le mais c'est
fort très sévère pour de vrai le mec est
doué dgac a fait ça il atteint puisque
le gars mesurer les 219 km regarder
quand il tourne et obligé d'anticiper et
parents drif le chien égard des peuples
se retournait et continuer sur le dos
adrift et 10 sur 10
une grand mère qui fait du shopping
c'est une excellente invention
effectivement elle est lente plus sain
propre le réalisme schiemann qui sait
faire du ski quand même voilà ça ce qui
c'est fantastique en plus c'est raccord
avec l'époque +1 point pour leur accord
tout de même il faut le noter
j'adore je pourrais faire tous les jours
les vidéos comme satan j'adore découvrir
ce que les gens font ce jeu quoi y
compris un mec qui fait du ski mais des
skis glissent pas trop quand même
un bombardier effectivement mais en plus
ce qui marche voyez quoi ils s'envolent
petit à petit on appuie sur rue et ça
s'ouvre et on peut lâcher les bons petit
à petit c'est effectivement le travail
d'un bombardier
d'où le nom du véhicule plus de pour
leur accord deux faces et aux véhicules
suivants ceci est une base solaires il
ya tellement d'éléments à l'écran que
mon pc est en train de mourir mais
vraiment bien c'est super bien d'avoir
une base aérienne
mais quand tu sais pas la contrôler
qu'elle fait cracher ton pc c'est moins
bien véhicule suivant un peu moins
compliqué s'il vous plaît on avait dit
juste un peu moins compris voilà c'est
juste un mec qui fait de la gym va
étrangement je trouve que c'est la
meilleure attraction d'aujourd'hui
félicitations théodore tu as gagné
cette petite peluche et vous voilà welch
ancien point de sept vidéo sur ben y
siègent n'hésitez pas les messieurs +
moi ça m'a fait kiffer de tester toutes
les constructions d'autres joueurs voilà
que soient ceux qui font des trucs un
peu moins de fuck ou ceux qui font des
trucs d'ingénieurs qui vraiment ne vont
pas à leur travail chaque jour pour
fabriquer des avions pour rester chez
eux ça briquets des avions d'ambitieuses
joyet c'était trop long j'en ai marre
alors
paul cette vidéo merci d'avoir regardé
j'ai tout le monde dit
[Musique]